christina vogg cares for her sick father
as well as her three children when she's
not busy at home
she works as a film producer and she
expects fair pay
but as is the case for so many women men
in her field earn more for the same work
germany has a gender wage gap of 22
percent one of the largest in the eu
demonstrators in berlin say that has to
stop
we are all equal under the law so it
doesn't make sense
when we have children it's a question of
who stays home who does the housework
and looks after the kids
and it comes down to who you see
i don't know if men earn all that much
more than women inequality in the
workplace is being addressed
we're on the right
but women's path minister manuela
schwesik is far from satisfied
she plans to introduce an equal wages
law that would require companies to
reveal inequalities
every company every administration
should ask itself
how high is the wage gap what are the
reasons for it and what can we do about
it says change also needs to happen at
home
only when men and women equally share
housework and child care
where women have more time to climb the
ladder at work